diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit der
camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
in diesem beruf dreht sich alles um das
menschliche leiden und darf es nicht zu
nah an sich heranlassen aber man sollte
auch keine mauer um sich herum bauen die
superhelden nehmen alles hin ich nicht
es gibt momente in denen ich stopp sagen
die pflegekräfte helfen anderen und
vergessen dabei sich selbst manche sind
sogar kränker als ihre patienten
man hat ständig angst etwas falsch zu
machen
keiner hat eine vorstellung davon was
das pflegepersonal heutzutage leistet
[Musik]
harte arbeitsbedingungen und ein
drohender personalmangel in diesem film
erzählen pflegefachkräfte offen über
ihren alltag zwischen leidenschaft und
zukunftsängsten
[Musik]
sieben uhr morgens an i s 27 jahre alt
und frisch ausgebildete pflegefachfrau
beginnt ihren arbeitstag in der
pädiatrie im spital morgen
[Musik]
ein zwölf stunden tag steht ihr bevor
manchmal ohne pause das ist normal in
diesem beruf für mich ist das kein job
wie jeder andere für mich ist es der
beste job jeder tag ist anders
an manchen morgen beginnt es schon
schwierig ich bin immer neugierig was
mich erwartet es gibt tage an denen man
die ganze zeit herum rennt andere sind
ruhiger aber das weiß man nie vorher
[Musik]
es ist das erste kind sie wollen das
beste für ihr baby geringes gewicht bei
der geburt war er 1890 gramm schwer
gestern hatte er einen zu niedrigen
blutdruck und musste überwacht werden es
gab aber keine anderen symptome außerdem
niedrigen blutdruck
[Musik]
die pädiatrie nimmt kinder von 0 bis 16
jahren auf
für eines geht es nach dem rapport
sofort los in der neonatologie bereitet
sie das frühstück für die frühgeborenen
vor
[Musik]
sie sind nicht so zerbrechlich niemand
denkt sind kämpfer die ganz kleinen sind
eine besondere herausforderung nicht
alle pflegefachfrauen mögen das man weiß
nicht weshalb sie schreien es ist
kompliziert wir haben es mit patienten
zu tun die nicht sagen was los ist sie
könne nicht sagen dass sie schmerzen
haben aber sie kommunizieren sehr stark
und darum geht es
ihre kommunikation zu verstehen und
darauf einzugehen
ich bin eine quasselte ich spreche viel
mit den babys sie berühren nicht sehr
sie bringen mich zum lachen
sag mal deinen augenbrauen
ich wusste dass ich mit kindern arbeiten
wollte bevor ich pflegefachfrau werden
wollte ja so ist gut unter die zunge die
zunge
es ist so spannend sie sind so zart
es ist eine art der pflege die es sonst
nirgends gibt man muss extrem kreativ
arbeiten auch bei den einfachsten
nichtinvasiven vorgänger
wenn ein zweijähriges kind sagt ich will
nicht dann muss man einen weg finden um
mit ihm mitzugehen
schritt nummer eins beim essen mund
aufmachen
intensivstation am universitätsspital
lausanne chuv carmen und ihre
kolleginnen machen eine kurze pause
auch sie sind seit sieben uhr auf den
beinen
bei ihren patienten geht es oft um leben
und tod
verkehrsunfälle herzinfarkte aneurysma
alles schwere fälle
hier hängt das leben am seidenen faden
carmen arbeitet seit zehn jahren auf der
intensivstation
mit der zeit hat sie sich an die
besondere umgebung gewöhnt ich mag den
stress in diesen situationen
ich mag die technische seite die es
neben der menschlichen auch immer
braucht es gibt eine tendenz unseren
beruf aufs technische zu beschränken
es stimmt gerade auf der intensivstation
braucht es viel technisches fachwissen
da sind so viele geräte
es ist auch eine sehr abwechslungsreiche
und interessante umgebung
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich diese
arbeit zehn jahre lang mache aber die
zeit vergeht schnell
ich gebe ihnen etwas gegen die schmerzen
um sie zu mobilisieren
an manchen tagen haben wir zeit für
pausen an anderen merkt man am ende des
tages dass man keine zeit hat er zu
trinken oder aufs klo zu gehen
der tag ist einfach vorbei 1 folgt aufs
andere
und plötzlich sind zwölf stunden
vergangen ohne dass man es merkt
als ich anfing in den ersten drei
monaten hatte ich immer ein flaues
gefühl im magen
es gab so viele patienten und ich fragte
mich ob ich das schon kann auf der
intensivstation herrscht eine besondere
atmosphäre
es ist eine eigene welt mit eigenen
geräusche eigenem aussehen eigenen
gerüchen ständigen reisen
am anfang ist das nicht einfach
ich sage jeweils zu den anfänger
kolleginnen fragt euch in den ersten
drei monaten nicht wie es euch geht
[Musik]
jeder handgriff am bett des patienten
muss setzen
die überwachung ist lebenswichtig wenn
etwas nicht korrekt durchgeführt wird
kann das konsequenzen für den patienten
haben ja man hat angst etwas zu
übersehen oder nicht richtig zu machen
[Musik]
man hat ständig angst etwas falsch zu
machen den ganzen tag für mich ist das
der größte stressfaktor als
berufseinsteigerinnen hatte ich große
angst etwas falsch zu machen so große
angst dass sich während monaten geweint
habe
jerome ist pflegefachmann in der
chirurgie im spital von morris er ist
einer der elf prozent männer welche
diesen beruf ergreifen
man verlässt die schule mit viel theorie
und viele überzeugungen im kopf dann
kommt man ins spital
dieses gewinne dass man zwar noch kennt
aus der zeit der praktiker damals war
man allerdings auch noch etwas geschützt
weil noch ausgebildet wurden
doch nun bekommt man einen rapport von
acht patienten und wird sich plötzlich
bewusst dass man die verantwortung für
sie trägt dass man vielen dass sie
vorher bekommen haben hat das etwas
geholfen
unglaublich ich habe keine schmerzen
mehr tiptop ich gebe ihnen nun noch die
insulinspritze ich könnte mir hier eine
zielscheibe draufzahlen
wir sind hier auf der inneren medizin
hier gibt es alles mögliche
wir sind nicht auf etwas spezialisiert
bei uns gibt es herz lungen und
nierenkrankheiten alte menschen junge
menschen menschen am ende ihres lebens
die begleitung ist nicht immer einfach
manchmal erinnert es dich an deine
familie am situationen wie du schon
erlebt hast mann begleitet das leiden
und die schmerzen der person welche
deine pflege benötigt aber auch die des
ganzen umfeld und das finde ich
schwierig
auch das gehört zum beruf den stress zu
meistern und tag für tag das leid zu
ertragen
wie lief es mit der verdauung keine
probleme sie war ganz ruhig ganz brav
bei einem kind das wir nach der geburt
aufgenommen haben wurde eine behinderung
festgestellt
wir haben das kind und seine familie
hier aufgenommen
wir haben sie unterstützt und angeleitet
es hat mich sehr berührt
es war für mich das erste mal daran
werde ich mich noch lange erinnern
[Musik]
unser weißer kittel soll ein bisschen
als schutzschild helfen auch die kurse
die sie uns beibringen wie man eine
professionelle distanz hält und eine
solche situation handhabt dennoch
bleiben wir hinter diesem weißen kittel
immer noch menschen mann lehrt uns in
der schule den tag zusammen mit dem
weißen kittel in der umkleidekabine
abzulegen
aber es gelingt nicht immer es kann
schwierig sein
ich kann die schranktür schlüsseln aber
die meiner seele nicht
manche situationen begleiten mich nach
hause
über mehrere tage einige begleiten mich
ein leben lang
das heißt nicht dass ich panik habe oder
mich schlecht fühle aber es ist einfach
so ich habe menschen getroffen die mich
geprägt haben und ich nicht vergessen
werde
[Musik]
die intensivpflege trägt ihren namen zu
recht zwölf stunden muss man durchhalten
atmen sie ruhig weiter wir sind gleich
durch heute betreut kamen zwei patienten
die schwer erkrankt sind
parallel dazu bereitet sie eine
80-jährige für den operationssaal vor
und organisiert den besuch des ehemanns
der in einer anderen abteilung der
klinik liegt
ich versuche ihren mann zu erreichen
dann komme ich zurück und geht ihnen
bescheid
am mittag sollte sie im op sein wenn er
kommen möchte das jetzt sein danach
bereite ich sie für die op vor machen
sie sich keine sorge wir immer an ihre
hände fest denn beim aufwachen zieht man
gerne den schlauch heraus kommt sie
wegen des wundverband am bauch in den op
saal zurück wir wollten den schlauch
nicht rausnehmen und ihn danach wieder
neu legen
hier geht es wirklich nicht gut es geht
ihr besser als gestern aber es könnte
schon besser sein
absolut sie bleibt so bis sie etwa in
einer stunde in den op kommt nach dem
eingriff werden wir schauen ob wir
diesen schlauch entfernen können
nein man ist da es ist eine emotionale
achterbahn man ehrlich sehr schwierige
situationen es geht immer um leben oder
tod
die grenze verschiebt sich und es kann
leicht vom einen ins andere kippen
bei dienstbeginn kann man sich nicht
vorstellen dass ein patient am abend
nicht mehr da ist
[Musik]
über schwierige erlebnisse reden zu
können sie loszuwerden das ist sehr
wichtig meine freundinnen sind sehr
wichtig für mich
wir tauschen uns über die arbeit aus und
auch darüber wie die arbeit unser leben
beeinflusst
die meisten meiner freundinnen sind auch
in der pflege tätig manchmal ist es
schwierig zu wissen ob man das gut
gemacht hat habe ich sie genügend
begleitet man muss die familie
unterstützen präsent sein ihnen alles
erklären sie reden lassen
ich erinnere mich an das was ein
familienvater mir sagt er als ein kind
im sterben lag ich habe meine partnerin
verloren ich bin also kein ehemann mehr
ich verliebe gerade mein einziges kind
ich bin kein vater mehr also sagen sie
mir wär ich noch bin ich spürte wie mir
die tränen kann ich konnte ihm nicht
sofort antworten
ich legte ihm die hand auf die schulter
und sagen wir verblieben einen moment in
stille und begleiteten seinen sohn
ich ging nach hause es hätte mich tief
getroffen
ich denke immer noch daran obwohl es
schon ein paar jahre ist diese person
vergesse ich nicht
als ich anfing hatte ich einen partner
der nicht in der pflege arbeitet
das war nicht einfach man kann sich
nicht in diese welt hinein fühlen wenn
man sie nicht kennt
anfangs kam ich nach hause und war noch
in gedanken ich habe mich immer
hinterfragt
ob ich alles richtig gemacht habe ich
ging den gedanken meinen tag nochmals
durch das war natürlich für meinen
partner nicht sehr angenehm
wer mag schon frustriert weil ich spät
nach hause kam und nicht gesprächig war
für außenstehende ist es nicht so
einfach zu verstehen sich auch über den
frust austauschen zu können das tut gut
pflegefachfrauen müssen sich mit der
allgegenwärtigkeit des todes abfinden
das ist umso schwieriger wenn man mit
kranken kindern arbeitet marien ist
pflegefachfrau in der genfer kinder
encore hämatologie ihre patienten sind
zwischen 0 und 16 jahre alt die meisten
haben leukämie
die behandlung ist lang ein emotionales
auf und ab dass nicht in jedem fall gut
endet
[Musik]
person geprüft
je älter ich werde umso empfindlicher
werde ich mein tod ist immer schwer zu
verkraften
man spürt wenn ein kind in der klinik im
sterben liegt die atmosphäre wiegt
schwer
man ist beunruhigt man ist da ohne
wirklich da zu sein jedenfalls ist das
beim lesen im krankenhaus
ich spüre dass ich da bin ohne wirklich
anwesend zu sein
man spürt diese schwere heute nimmt
martin in arno und seine mutter in
empfang
arno ist an leukämie erkrankt gehen wir
ins zimmer 202 wie immer für arno und
seine mutter ist marin eine verbündete
im kampf gegen den krebs
wie viel pro veneto nimmst du 100
milligramm tabletten jeden abend auf
nüchternen magen
vor allem wenn mir übel ist muss ich
aufpassen was ich esse keine großen
warmen mahlzeiten
das haben wir ausprobiert ist gar nicht
schlecht
ja das ist gut für die proteinzufuhr ist
es eine creme er eine art milch wenn ich
nicht essen kann nehme ich das auch wenn
es keine malz hat ersetzt marien ist
mehr als eine pflegefachfrau sie ist
eine vertraute ich bewundere sie was sie
leistet ist nicht selbstverständlich
sie hört sich den ganzen tag die sorgen
der eltern an und auch die der kinder
sie muss für alles lösungen finden
manchmal auch trösten
man möchte sich in marinen festklammern
sie ist der rote faden
wie geht's dir damit dass du die haare
verloren hast im gesicht zugenommen
heißt es ist unangenehm aber ich weiß
dass es vorbei geht das kommt wieder in
ordnung
legst du dich hin ich möchte dann
gelungen abhören
ich erzähle hier wirklich viel wie ich
mich fühle wie ich als er trage wie ich
es erlebe sie unterstützt mich in
schwierigen momenten wenn es mir nicht
so gut geht
psychisch und physisch das tröstet mich
denn es ist nicht leicht die ganze zeit
in dieser etwas restriktiven spital
umgebung zu sein
restriktiv sie schafft es immer eine
lösung aufzuzeigen oder einen zu
ermuntern an die zukunft zu denken denn
das ist wichtig der blick nach vorne der
seelisch aspekt wird oft vernachlässigt
dabei ist der absolut wesentlich um
gesund zu werden
[Musik]
diese zeichnung gefällt mir sehr ich bin
immer gerührt wenn die kinder etwas für
mich zeichnen ein sehr schönes geschenk
[Musik]
je länger ich im berufsleben stehe desto
wichtiger ist für mich die beziehung zum
patienten
das macht den begriff der pflegefachfrau
so wertvoll die beziehung die man zum
patienten
[Musik]
vor allem in der onkologie sind es ja
chronische krankheit mann begleitet die
patienten langfristig
eine vertrauensbeziehung zum patienten
aufbauen
das ist für pflegefachleute der kern
ihres berufs und das braucht zeit und
diese kostbare zeit fehlt immer mehr so
der allgemeine tenor in der branche
selbst in einer regionalen institutionen
mit familiärer atmosphäre wie im
krankenhaus von mars gibt es immer
wieder frustrationen wie geht's dir
spürst du schon ein wenig das ist doch
schon was
kennst du das hat man dir das in der
notaufnahme gezeigt damit kannst du mir
zeigen wie wir es tut
wie ist es jetzt gerade sehr gut
ich frage dich später nochmal wir warten
darauf dass das morphium wirkt siehst du
die rote taste wenn irgendetwas sein
sollte dann drückst du drauf aber ich
komme bald noch einmal vorbei ich bin
schon weg häufig ist der frust mit
zeitmangel verbunden hätten gerne mehr
zeit um die patienten zu umsorgen eine
bessere beziehung zu ihnen aufzubauen
und einfach auch nur für die pflege
manchmal gilt das nicht dann denke ich
ich hätte es besser oder anders machen
soll
jetzt ziehen wir dich mal aus um dich zu
wiegen
bist du bereit da ist die lage
ich brauche eine viertelstunde bis ich
mir die oben gabentisch ist
co-präsidentin der waadtländer sektion
des schweizer berufsverband der
pflegefachfrauen und pflegefachmänner
sbk bei ihr treffen erfahrungsberichte
vieler kollegen ein
[Musik]
beim berufsverband stellen wir fest dass
es in allen institutionen im kanton
waadt probleme gibt vielerorts fehlt
personal
es fehlt an nachwuchs an leuten die bei
einem krankheitsfall oder als
mutterschaftsvertretung einspringen
können das lastet schwer auf den teams
die das dann abdecken
die leute sollen die gleiche arbeit
leisten dieselbe pflegequalität bieten
mit weniger personal
das ist eine kafkaeske situation damit
lässt sich schwer umgehen
der stress wird auf die nächste schicht
übertragen und am ende der kette ist der
patient
[Musik]
der zeitmangel und seine folgen für die
qualität der pflege beschäftigt auch die
ehemalige pflegefachfrau und heutige
ausbildnerin an orte wo in der pflege
hatte ich etwa zehn verschiedene
anstellen abgesehen davon dass die
beziehung zu meinem partner wegen meinem
beruf immer schwieriger wurde stellte
ich fest dass auch der pflegealltag
immer fordernder wurde
[Musik]
es nervt wenn man nicht die zeit hat die
grundlegendsten tätigkeiten zu erledigen
man hat nicht einmal die zeit eine
patientin in der nacht die 2,5 meter zur
toilette zu begleiten
man ist für 30 betten verantwortlich
unter keine zeit um auf die klinger zu
reagieren
die patientin bittet dann um eine wende
obwohl sie nicht in kontinent ist aber
niemand hat zeit wie zu gehen ein
einzelnes beispiel aber so geschehen es
ist schockierend
das ärgert mich an orte wo ist überzeugt
patienten und pflegepersonal sind
gleichermaßen opfer dieser situation
der pflegefachfrau welche der jungen
frauen nicht helfen konnte aufs wc zu
gehen geht es nicht denn sie ist
unzufrieden mit ihrer leistung
natürlich sind das ausnahmesituationen
aber wenn es passiert dann ist das ein
alarmsignal
ein weiteres alarmzeichen viele
pflegefachleute steigen vorzeitig aus
ihrem beruf aus 2018 veröffentlicht die
tageszeitung welt kathrein bericht einer
jungen pflegefachfrau die den beruf nach
nur zwei jahren an den nagel hängte ich
will keine pflegefachfrau sein die keine
zeit hat alles muss immer schneller
gehen
wir sind schachfiguren roboter es
beschäftigt mich dass eine junge frau
nach nur zwei jahren ihren beruf an den
nagel hängt und etwas anderes anfängt
obwohl sie drei oder vier jahre in die
ausbildung investiert
die junge pflegefachfrau musste sich neu
orientieren
über die für sie schwierige zeit im
pflegeberuf will sie nicht reden
es ist nicht einfach für die
pflegefachfrauen die balance zu halten
zwischen ihrem ideal und der
arbeitsrealität der berichte in wörth
katar hat auch anis bewegt aus gutem
grund ich kenne sie sehr gut wir waren
im selben jahrgang in der ausbildung
sie ist nicht die erste und wird wohl
auch nicht die letzte sein der das
passiert
viele pflegefachleute gäben ihren beruf
vor dem ruhestand auf einige schon sehr
sehr früh es ist gut dass einige den mut
haben für alle zu sprechen
laut statistik wollen mehr als 46
prozent aller pflegefachkräfte den beruf
vor der pensionierung aufgeben
ich hatte nur ein stethoskop es gab kein
anderes ich musste mein eigenes benutzen
obwohl ich das aus dem patientenzimmer
hätte nehmen sollen laut ewo
unterrichtet pflege an der
fachhochschule in lausanne
für sie spielt die ausbildung eine große
rolle um berufs abbrüche verhindern zu
können
die nachwuchsförderung ist sehr wichtig
man muss die wichtigkeit dieses berufs
verdeutlichen und die damit verbundene
komplexität hervorheben
es ist nicht ganz einfach spaß an der
arbeit zu haben
man ist ständig mit der realität
konfrontiert als ausbildnerin muss man
weiter geben wie man mit dieser realität
umgehen kann
in der erst aus bildung müssten wir mehr
tun um die auszubildenden besser darauf
vorzubereiten was sie in diese nicht
ganz einfachen system erwartet
passiv erzielt
[Musik]
im krankenhaus umfeld stieß ich
irgendwann an meine grenzen
das machte für mich irgendwie keinen
sinn mehr was sich im operationssaal tag
machte eine op nach der anderen
der teamgeist dies immer mehr nach alles
war strikt festgelegt
[Musik]
wie gehts habe sie gut geschlafen
die menschliche seite dass man sich
austauschen konnte das gab es nicht mehr
ich konnte so nicht weitermachen ich sah
keinen sinn mehr in dem beruf den ich
gewählt hatte also habe ich mich
entschieden zu kündigen
doch luisa gab ihren beruf nicht auf
nach mehreren jahren als op
pflegefachfrau ist sie nun
selbstständige pflegefachfrau so ist sie
weiterhin in kontakt mit menschen in
diesem beruf dreht sich alles um das
menschliche leiden was macht man damit
wie kommt man da heraus wie übersteht
man die zeit nach dem man zum ersten mal
den tod begegnet den leid
das sind alles dinge die uns
beschäftigen und in dieser sinnsuche
finden auch den grund für unsere
berufswahl
diesen faden darf man nicht verlieren
denn viele lassen sich entmutigen
das sieht aber schön aus es scheint gut
zu heilen
das sind tolle neuigkeiten ich vertraue
ihnen das universum hat mir den
geburtsort afrika beschert wo jeder
ältere mensch ein geschichtsbuch ist sie
haben viel zu erzählen
das ist spannend
mich interessieren die geschichten
dieser menschen
denn anhand der geschichten lernt nun
sie kennen 11,7 das ist gut
diese zwei gefällt mir mit der atmung
klappt es heute gut hast du dir genau
gemerkt was du dem arzt sagst was ich
dem arzt sagen soll das ist mir sehr gut
geht
nein gesagt sie war hand
[Musik]
ich habe meinen beruf immer sehr ernst
genommen
ich habe immer nur geschuftet es waren
sehr schwierige situationen in der
häuslichen pflege hat man nicht immer
das passende material und eines tages
machte meinen rücken schlug ich hatte
vorher keine schmerzen
ich konnte mich plötzlich nicht mehr
bewegen konnte er nicht mehr arbeiten
gehen
das war sehr schwierig und sehr
schmerzhaft
es dauerte mehrere monate ich wusste
nicht was ich machen sollte damit es
besser geht schließlich entließ mich
mein arbeitgeber
ich will nicht die einzige was passiert
vielen pflegenden der rücken ist
gefährdet in diesem beruf film bonner
professor
manchmal ist die last buchstäblich zu
groß
manchmal hat man keine andere wahl als
den beruf aufzugeben
oft ist das schmerzhaft als anita die
häusliche krankenpflege aufgeben musste
wandte sie sich der alternativmedizin zu
heute hat sie eine heilpraxis und gibt
kurse um das körperliche bewusstsein zu
stärken
spürt eure arme an welchen stellen am
arm hat der kontakt liegen beide arme
gleich ihr könnt jederzeit eine pause
machen
unter ihren kundinnen sind viele von der
arbeit erschöpfte pflegefachkräfte die
leute denen ich begegne sind wirklich
erschöpft
manchmal sind die pflegefachleute
kränker als ihre patienten
es gibt solche die keine pause machen
nicht aufs klo gehen oder nichts trinken
es ist keine berufung
ich mag diesen ausdruck nicht aber wenn
man den pflegeberuf ergreift dann geht
es darum sich um andere
so kümmern und dabei vergisst man dann
häufig sich selbst ich habe damals zu
wenig gut zu mir geschaut dass mein
rücken mich im stich ließ kalt nur meine
bedürfnisse ernster zu nehmen die
selbstlose aufopferung anitas worte
erinnern an das bild einer
krankenschwester von früher nonnen die
kostenlos für den allmächtigen arzt
arbeiten
[Musik]
bilder und worte aus einer anderen zeit
die sich aber hartnäckig im kollektiven
bewusstsein halten genauso wie andere
überholte klischees haben sie schon
einmal krankenschwester in der
bildersuche von google eingegeben
dort tauchen alle möglichen
krankenschwestern outfits auf etwa die
sexy krankenschwester mit einem so
kurzen rock und dem kleinen ding auf dem
kopf am besten noch mit einem dekolleté
bis zum bauchnabel mit solchen bildern
wollen wir nicht in verbindung gebracht
werden eine kollegin sagte einmal ich
arbeite ich bin hier nicht auf der
automesse mein aussehen ist unwichtig
wichtig sind meine kompetenzen am
patientenbett daran sollte ich gemessen
werden und nicht an meinem äußeren
klare regelmäßige atmung alles klar das
kalium ist wieder gefallen
75 blutplättchen als pflegefachfrau hat
man kompetenzen ein fachwissen und eine
professionelle haltung
es ist aber nicht immer einfach dass man
gehört wird von gewissen anderen
experten im gesundheitsbereich
die pflegefachfrau steht am
patientenbett wir sind zwölf stunden bei
jetzt drücken dass gleich ein wenig der
arzt macht die visite schaut punktuell
beim patienten vorbei aber wir sind
immer an seiner seite
das niveau unserer kompetenz hat einen
deutlichen einfluss auf die pflege diese
verzerrte alte sicht der
krankenschwester sowie eine nonne ist
davon grenzen wir uns deutlich ab sie
ist helmut dynamisch stabil
heute morgen hatte sie einen
schwächeanfall die verrückte lange bis
wir uns von den ärzten emanzipierten
heute stehen wir in einem
partnerschaftlichen arbeitsverhältnis
und das ist auch gut so
[Musik]
die einschätzung der pflegefachfrauen
hat heute gewicht
habt ihr eine verlegung veranlasst nein
er kommt zu uns wieso willst du es
instabil
china ist seit 32 jahren pflegefachfrau
heute arbeitet sie in der geriatrischen
notaufnahme der genfer uniklinik sie
verurteilt den zustand des patienten
autonom die ärzte kommen erst später
dazu noch vor kurzem wäre dies undenkbar
gewesen
der beruf der pflegefachfrau beinhaltet
nicht nur die pflege auf anweisung eines
arztes hin
wir müssen mitdenken und für den
patienten die beste lösung finden
ich nehme ihren arm
ja ich weiß das ist unangenehm manchmal
verhandeln wir mit den ärzten sie sagen
etwa die patientin bekommt einen urin
katheter ich frage zurück aus welchem
grund sagen
die frau kann aufs klo gehen da ist kein
katheter nötig solche sachen wörtlich
wir sind nicht da um stupide die
anordnung eines arztes auszuführen
wir sprechen auf augenhöhe miteinander
nicht von der kleinen krankenschwester
zum übergeordneten arzt sei es nie so
sondern eher dass wir auf gleicher ebene
sind da ist kein ungleichgewicht geht es
ihm gut
wie sind die werte ja er ist stabil
das pflegefachpersonal will mit seinen
kompetenzen ernst genommen werden
vanessa ist pflegefachfrau im bereich
suchthilfe heute organisiert sie die
entlassung von bad ist ein ehemaliger
drogenabhängiger der hier wegen krebs
behandelt wurde
sie waren sehr besorgt als sie ins
krankenhaus kam ich dachte das sei meine
endstation
dass ich nie mehr nach hause kommen
das sind tolle neuigkeiten dass ich die
möglichkeit hat diese krankheit besiegen
zu können
ich lege keine infusionen mir das könnte
ich nicht mehr in meinem bereich
suchterkrankungen arbeite ich nicht mehr
mit material
ich arbeite mit den emotionen die von
meinem gegenüber kommen gehe auf seine
situation ein
[Musik]
meine tägliche arbeit besteht darin
vorherzusehen was auf den patienten
zukommt ich helfe ihm sein ziel zu
erreichen begleitet
ich glaube alle pflegefachkräfte tun
dies einfach mit unterschiedlichen
mitteln
meine mittel sind vor allem zu hören und
sprechen
haben sie ein paar schuhe verbreitet
viele jahre ausbildung genügen manchmal
nicht um die alten vorbehalte der ärzte
zu zerstreuen
es ist nicht immer ganz einfach zu
beschreiben was ich mache was ich sagen
kann ist wo ich beginne und wohin nicht
möchte dass weiß ich im voraus
aber es gibt natürlich immer
überraschungen denn der patient bringt
seine realität sein leben mit
es ist schwierig zu erklären ich glaube
die kluft zwischen ärzten und
pflegepersonal besteht nach wie vor
ich sehe es jeden tag natürlich gibt es
enorm auch wenn der ärzte und ärztinnen
die an die unterschiedlichen fähigkeiten
der anderen klassen
andere glauben immer noch dass alles zur
medizin gehört außer der dienstleistung
das ist manchmal frustrierend denn ein
arzt und pflege fach sind nicht
dieselben berufe aber sie ergänzen sich
[Musik]
ich rufe sie an wegen der knochenmark
funktion von maria b ich wollte das
heute noch mit ihnen besprechen aber ich
würde lieber noch die ergebnisse
abwarten
falls es ein problem gibt melde ich mich
dann könnten wir einen anderen patienten
vorziehen
zurück in der onkologischen pädiatrie
marie in boberow hat eine lange
weiterbildung einen masterabschluss in
pflege gemacht an der uniklinik genf
wurde speziell für sie eine neue stelle
geschaffen
sie arbeitet unter der supervision eines
arztes genießt aber große freiheiten
in meiner karriere habe ich immer
versucht als pflegefachfrau eine gewisse
autonomie zu erlangen
ich bin auch sonst im leben ziemlich
unabhängig und wollte das auch in meinem
berufsalltag teil ihrer selbständigen
arbeit marin hat eine eigene
sprechstunde für ihre patienten
heute hat janis einen termin bei ihr ein
jugendlicher bei dem sich die leukämie
zurückbildet ist etwas passiert dass du
nicht mehr so motiviert bist dass du
keine lust hast aufzustehen und in die
schule zu gehen
ich muss aufstehen aber ich bin so müde
aber was passiert in der schule
ich habe keine motivation mehr willst du
dich körperlich müde oder ist es eher
vom gefühl her
die pflegefachfrauen treten langsam aus
dem schatten ans zeigen ihre kompetenzen
das ist ein wendepunkt in unserem beruf
der zug ist in bewegung wir dürfen ihn
nicht verpassen
aus sorge um seinen berufsstand
lancierte der schweizer berufsverband
der pflegefachfrauen und
pflegefachmänner sbk 2018 die initiative
für eine starke pflege sie ist im
parlament noch hängig
[Musik]
die initiative ist wichtig weil sie
aufzeigt dass ein massiver
personalmangel droht es braucht gut
ausgebildetes personal welches mit den
patienten und deren komplexen
situationen umgehen können wenn bis
20.30 nichts unternommen wird dann fragt
sich wer uns dann pflegen wird die
bevölkerung wird das immer mehr bewusst
viele leute sagen mir ich wusste gar
nicht wie viel arbeit das erst bevor ich
hier verdient wurde auf den politikern
wird klar dass etwas geschehen muss
damit man einerseits leute ausbilden und
andererseits die bereits ausgebildeten
behalten kann
viele junge pflegefachleute beschäftigt
der blick in die zukunft
ich profitiere davon dass ich noch jung
bin wenn ich das so sagen darf wenn man
erst gerade die schule verlassen hat
dann will man die welt verändern
im lauf der zeit nimmt an die euphorie
etwas ab das wird mir wohl auch
passieren
dazu kommt noch die körperliche und auch
die seelische erschöpfung
ja man braucht einen langen atem wenn
man 30 jahre in diesem beruf durchhalten
will
ich weiß nicht ob ich noch daran glaube
die welt verändern zu können
aber ich habe noch die kraft die lust
und auch den enthusiasmus um dinge zu
vollbringen zu lernen jeden tag etwas
weiterkommen nicht einbringen
das würde ich gern
es gibt tage da komme ich nach hause und
bin stolz darauf was ich machen konnte
was ich für den patienten oder seine
familie tun konnte ich sage mir ich habe
gegeben was ich konnte
an anderen tagen sage ich mir das
hättest du besser machen können und bin
frustriert weil ich es tatsächlich
besser hätte machen können die patienten
sagen mir wir werden schon allein durch
ihren anblick gesund ich bin ein
dinosaurier in diesem beruf 32 jahre
eine lange zeit
ich wollte eigentlich friseurin werden
das bringt die leute auch zum lachen
aber es hat genau so mit menschen zu tun
der kontakt mit den haaren mit den
menschen meine mutter sagte nein nein du
wirst pflegefachfrau damit du dich dann
einmal um mich kümmern kannst dank ihr
bin ich also in diesem beruf gelandet
heute bin ich sehr dankbar denn ich
konnte mich verwirklichen in diesem
beruf
zündet lieber ein kleines licht anstatt
über dunkelheit zu klagen
was hat sie geschrieben ich bin stolz
auf meinen werdegang
ich bin stolz darauf und ich sind
wirklich und wenn man einmal
pflegefachfrau war dann bleibt man das
hier immer prozedur ist es ist wichtig
den bis zu behalten
[Musik]
das ist kein beruf den man per zufall
ergreift wenn man ihn ausübt dann glaubt
man an gewisse werte solidarität
interesse neugier aufs gegenüber eine
gewisse offenheit lust auf begegnungen
wenn man sich nicht für andere menschen
interessiert dann wird man wohl nicht
pflegefachfrau oder pflegefachmann
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von bea genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
der camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922